Professor Kaku says that the problems
emerge only when you try to integrate
quantum mechanics with relativity Theory
so what is he saying do not try to
integrate them this is what is so
beautiful in science that you integrate
different perspectives have you said
that to the Young Einstein relativity
Theory would never emerge because you
would say to Einstein you have a problem
you have a electromagnetism on the one
side you have galileon invariance on the
other on the other side and you have a
problem when you try to integrate them
don't integrate them Einstein go home
and and there will be no theory of
relativity every time that there is in
physics two theories which are not
compatible with one another that is the
beginning of of of the
adventure